thomas bonsoir alors c'est un dénouement
qui était attendu
oui le feuilleton a enfin pris fin
puisque évidemment la pression
s'accentuait ces derniers jours au tour
d'andrew cuomo visez donc par une
enquête pour des faits de harcèlement
sexuel des baisers les étreintes non
désirées un environnement de travail
toxiques au total ce sont 168 pages
d'investigation qui avait été révélé
lors d'une conférence de presse de la
procureur de l'état de new york c'était
la semaine dernière andrew cuomo avait
alors réagi en niant ces accusations et
puis la pression s'était accentuée
notamment après les déclarations du
président américain joe biden qui avait
été interrogé sur le sort de ce
gouverneur démocrate de l'état de new
york et joe biden avait appelé andrew
cuomo a démissionné c'est donc chose
faite dans une allocution qui a été
diffusé à la mi-journée ici aux etats
unis je propose d'écouter un extrait
justement de ces propos tenus par an dro
comme aujourd'hui
je pense qu'étant donné les
circonstances
la meilleure façon pour moi d'aider et
de me retirer et de laisser le
gouvernement reprendre le pouvoir
c'est donc ce que je vais faire parce
que je travaille pour vous et faire la
bonne chose c'est faire la bonne chose
pour vous
[Musique]
parce que comme on dit il ne s'agit pas
de moi il s'agit de nous cattier o'cool
l'a10 gouverneur est intelligente et
compétente cette transition doit être
transparent nous avons des choses à
faire
je suis très inquiet pour le variant
delta et vous devriez l'être aux siens
mais elle peut se mettre au courant
rapidement c'est ma démission sera
effective dans 14 jours
alors à l'issue de ces quatorze
prochains jours c'est la numéro deux de
l'état de new york qui va apprendre la
place d'andrew comeau elle s'appelle
cathy haute soule elle sera la première
femme à diriger cet état progressiste de
new york alors andré comeau lui cela met
fin à dix ans de sa tête à la tête de
cet état de new york il avait été élu en
2011 il s'était notamment fait connaître
ces derniers mois pour ses prises de
position très dure envers donald trump
ans au plein coeur de la pandémie il
s'était mis en opposition frontale avec
le président des états unis avant d'être
rattrapé par une affaire puisqu'il y
avait eu une affaire de personnes
testées positives qui avait été renvoyé
dans des maisons de retraite dans l'état
de new york cela avait déjà terni sa
réputation et puis donc ces accusations
de harcèlement sexuel ont mis un coût
quasi définitif à sa carrière lui qui
était parfois pressenti pour un jour
peut-être se présenter à la
présidentielle ici aux etats unis andrew
cuomo qui va donc quitter ses fonctions
d'ici 14 jours après ces enquêtes et
surtout après la pression qui s'est
accentuée ces derniers jours puisque
outre les déclarations de joe biden ont
assisté à des démissions notamment de la
part de certaines de ses assistantes et
puis il y avait des enquêtes d'opinion
qui se succédaient dans l'état de new
york faisant état du fait que la plupart
des habitants de cet état de new york
réclamer la démission du gouverneur un
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnin en direct de
washington